uh before i launch into this i just
kind of want to explain what's going on
when i'm since this is a developer
meetup
i'm actually trying to replicate on a
much smaller screen of course
pixel-wise actually how the development
works
so um what what you kind of see a split
screen here
uh usually i often don't have the thing
on the on the right that's actually just
my phone so
this is literally just um my phone
yeah so this um
and then this is an editor so usually
there's many editors
and you type the code in and you see
something happen on the other thing
on the other side uh so um i have been
i'm very new to closure actually um
i don't know if a few months into it is
new or old
but i have i've only been using closure
for about three or four months
i don't have a computer science degree i
kind of have everything
all the everything's stacked against me
however
um i'm developing this really fast
um which is great so i'm going to um
yeah so it's it's data driven mobile app
development
i'd like to acknowledge um some people
first my friends and family
um i met some of the people are here
actually um the
new lab at the brooklyn navy yard um
zago llc which is a great design firm
uiux firm in town and then my colleagues
niels jim larinda
and mike who are not here but i want to
acknowledge them
in case they see the video and of course
all of you
um and it's um you know for me
just being on the irc group and
you know looking at all the various
forums it was was really
what got me from point a to point b
um so these are the things i'm going to
talk about this evening
um just the motivations of why i'm doing
this
um the things that i researched in
preparing to do this
um the underlying technology which
enables me to do this
and then a few more specific things
which
i'll discuss later um
so why did i want to do mobile
development differently
than firing up xcode and you know
writing up a binary or firing up the
specific tools for android
why did i make my own thing and there's
a few reasons
one is this i've been doing mobile
development for a long time
and you have this thing where you write
the code and
you compile it into an image or a binary
then you have to send it to your phone
then it has to boot up and then you're
kind of in the same
state every time you boot up you have to
write some kind of script to get it
somewhere else
you have you sort of have to start over
every time you want to see a change in
what you're doing
um so what one thing that just is
natural with closure
and i think one thing that draws a lot
of people to it is its dynamic
capability
so you can kind of see what you're
working on while you're working on it
um so there's um there's the the repel
the run
evaluate um read evaluate print loop
so with mobile development there's this
compile
image flash run loop so you have um
you have like you type your code in here
and you hit one of those buttons up here
and then you wait a little while and
then you get this and this is either a
simulator or it runs in your thing
and if you make a change you kind of
have to start over each time
so this is a bit of a reaction to that
or trying to get around that
um also there's um
cross-platform is a big motivator so
there's android there's
there's ios there's html5 there's
now you know samsung has t-zen so
everyone kind of has a different phone
so let's um and this is everyone's
trying to there's many solutions this
problem um
and i've you know just have the html5
one
but i'm going to use html5 but i also
want to
access the native software and hardware
of the phone
so um like bluetooth for instance so as
part of this little exercise
you see like a number changing in the
upper corner of the
little blue bar hr one seven i'm gonna
try to relax
can you guys guess what this is that's
real that's actually quite high
when i was rehearsing i was seldom over
90. um
it's just what you know what presenting
does um
so i can access the native hardware so
i'm wearing a bluetooth heart monitor
and i'm and it's talking the phone and
we're looking at how nervous i get
cardiac arrest
actually if we had skin galvanization we
could kind of figure out if i'm
lying
yeah okay so uh also on data transfer
there's there's some i'm not going to
get too much of this this is a smaller
part of a much larger project
there's a whole network stack and
there's a whole um marshalling data back
and forth
from places um i'm not really going to
get in that i'm going to talk mostly
about the client
but the the goal is to have apps that
are like data aware
so uh something that can react to
um either things on the on the phone
itself or peripherals like the one i'm
wearing
or a weather report a financial report
anything that could possibly be coming
in
that's that's a huge goal here state
management
i'm going to skip over that until later
and
i want to do all this but also want to
minimize the complexity
um so i'm gonna run down some precursors
so this is some of you may be familiar
with some of these projects
um a lot of them were just vastly
inspiring
um others were sort of
um so there's there's android uh closure
implementations and
uh one one version is this um there's
like a closure rebel so
it it provides like a command line you
can type in some code
and evaluate it on your phone so this is
the kind of the first foray into mobile
closure i had
and this is actually how i learned
closure um just
like when i was killing time on you know
on the plane
um you know just typing things into the
into the
thing and seeing the result um so that's
one
so that was the first one uh there's
there's some cross compilers there's
closure c
which can uh take your closure code and
compile it into
the c language which can run native um
on on phones and really and sees old
school it can run anywhere
there's closure m which is objective c
which is the basic the base language for
all of apple's products
so ios you program an objective c so if
you wanted to program enclosure
there is closure m which is a compiler
to let you do that
i messed around with that a little bit
um i borrow
some api stuff from jquery i think
everyone does i don't
use jquery in any of this but i'm i have
to acknowledge it
uh but here is where uh
the major influence is these last four
things
um facebook i promise never to like
complain about it again um because
they make some great technologies and
they have this library called react
which um was which made this
kind of took me on a tangent which was
really
uh the right thing to do so i'm going to
talk about virtual doms and stuff like
that
uh there's a there actually is a closure
script wrapper
around ohm uh or round react called
om and it's excellent uh however
i not using it actually maybe i got too
far before i found it i don't know
um but i think my api is different
there's this project from
um the the cons to the conjures like
people were talking about closure west
it's like the big conventions where
we all get together i haven't i've yet
to go to one but i saw a presentation on
this thing called web foui which
uh was influential and then um so light
table is this
kind of text editor that i'm using and
it got open source in in january
and there's so but there's also some
blog posts uh
chris granger the founder of it did
before he released it
so i'm using it to develop but also the
concepts in it i took borrowed
so i'm double acknowledging it
um okay so again here's the principles
so i'm going to breeze through all this
background and then we're going to
then i'm going to show some some demos
and then for the last like five minutes
i'll just hack around and we can try
stuff um
so we're cross-platform so we're using
html5
the web is everywhere this code uses
clojurescript it uses the
um the g closure or the with the closure
with the
s compiler um compiles a very small
javascript binary and that's what runs
um
so it's a debuggable testable
because you're just using html5 stuff so
i find um this one tool
fairly indispensable if i can find it
um
so this is called winery and it's like
right now it's just printing my heart
rate but
it's uh it allows you to inspect um
the actual html that's running in the
browser so
there's this what we're looking at here
is a is the text representation of
what's rendering on the screen
um and if i bring this back up how can i
do this
let me try okay so this if someone
hasn't done a lot of web programming i
think it's worth for me to take a minute
or two
and do this so we have the visual
representation
here but what it really is to the
browser
sort of um is this stuff so there's all
these components and i can use this tool
and i can um i can kind of inspect
around
and if i if i highlight over something
it'll so
i'm that's the actual rep the
non-graphical representation and when i
hover over it with my cursor
you know we see it there so it's just
kind of a way of inspecting your thing
if i think people who are doing a lot of
html development
are using these tools already um so i
leverage these
um and there's there's a testing suite
called selenium which
gives you a virtual person who can
um touch the screen and do all kinds of
things you write a script
and they can test it's you create a
virtual person
who touches the screen does things in
sequence so if you want to
do hardcore testing uh that's a good way
um and again uh the dynamic
nature of this i'll demonstrate in a sec
and then
these apps are event driven so we want
we need to listen to user input
um we want to listen to the hardware of
the phone
um we want to listen to peripherals for
peripheral bulls do you hear that
um like fitbit and heart rate monitors
and stuff like that
and we also want to access data network
data sources
again underlying technologies so this is
the actual stuff
html css javascript
cordova is a bridge between html and
the hardware on the phone um
closurescript which i already described
line again which is a build tool and
then ide is light table which you don't
have to use i just prefer to use it
um the the main reason for these slides
is just when i post this later
people will know what to look at
all right so with that
so the last so what can we build with
these
um is what i'm warming up to
um so here's just kind of the basic
building blocks um
we have this we write enclosure
actually we build closure data
structures um
and they're analogous to html dom
elements so we
have a thing tag button and it can have
some content so
it becomes um so it's actually the same
output as the default uh xml
closure xml parser so if anyone's ever
parsed xml so you can just take an
xml or html file parse it into this
you can take an svg file which i'll do
later and parse it into this
and then this is the um this is the data
structure you wind up manipulating
so this is a button um it just has some
text in it
this is a button that happens i have a
red background and it also has
some different text in it so an app is
just
composing these things together
but you can also do custom tags so
a button is just a generic
html thing but if i want a special kind
of button
i can do um i can define my own thing
and this is kind of a truncated version
i'll show you the real
the real thing is actually here um so
i'm def tagging
i have just the name of it i can have um
some css which gets uh which is the
style
like the colors the the fonts and stuff
like that that gets compiled down
and um just becomes text um
and then uh a node so it's actually
it's gonna this is either a function
it's one of those um
it's either gonna be one of these
structures itself
or a function that returns that and i'll
demonstrate this in a second
so here it is um so this is actually the
button so let's look
um so now we're here is this font a good
size for everyone
okay so here we are so we're defining
our target button um
and these this is just a css so
styles positions margins uh alignment
uh background this should all be very
familiar if you've done any css
the only difference is it's in closure
so the basic idea is that you merge tabs
into the definition
exactly that is multiple actions yes
and you can have tags that refer to
other tags it's just a way of compo
of composing yeah um
and then finally so we have a lot of
styles for this
um and so this is not actually
one uh html this this is not one html
thing like a button it's actually a
composition of many
and so i'm kind of nesting things so now
we'll get to where i do that
so in this case i have this thing called
this other piece of data called node
and it's actually a function that
returns one
so i'm passing in the the i'm passing in
the original one
this and then i can modify it
and spit out a new output which is going
to be this
so you'll see that i'm grabbing data
from that
um so yeah so this um
so this string here winds up
right coming in through this argument
and i'm
i'm adding new stuff to it so i'm
changing it to a div
i'm putting all these these are other
tags i'm putting inside of it
and then finally in the label
i grab the content from that and i plop
it in there
and so the output is this kind of nested
things so it's actually
uh it's three divs which makes that
uh is is that sort of clear okay and if
yeah if anyone has questions i think
it's best to do them like right away
um then then procrastinate how do you
destroy it
uh yeah i'm going to show that that's
when we get to state that's like the
next thing so no that's that's
great that you're leading into it um
state um
so we have and this is a concept in in
facebook react
where you have this you don't use
um you have one object which is
a fake version of what the browser sees
so you have a virtual document object
model
and then you have you you so
here's the thing in html uh rendering
the stuff on the screen is slow
um when you add a button when you add
something
it's slow in the more the more complex
your your the more stuff you have in
your application
the more complex it is so you don't
really want the breath you want the
browser to see the bare minimum
um you want it to render the bare
minimum so we have this huge
um state model and we're only
selectively rendering
the parts of it we want to render any
given time so
um so yeah it's all um and i think this
is where i'm going to start to show
how little i know about closure um but
this is we have one big atom um which is
like the root node
we call it app and then um you
then you can just the state itself just
looks like this
so we could have a menu bar we could
have some buttons we could have some
content
and that so this is um
this doesn't have to be a one-to-one so
this this is on
on the phone right it's completely
decoupled from rendering
so yes this is becoming html at the end
it's it's
making html buttons on on the phone or
on the browser
but you could actually have many
renderers so
all the html render is is it's one pro
it's a protocol that has a render
function and you pass it the state and
it renders it
so you could have um and you can
register new renders
with the state so you could have a
renderer that
actually um writes the app on a times
square billboard
you could have um a renderer that makes
an led blink
so it's it's um it's not one to one
it's completely decoupled
um and this is how we change the state
we
it's a little bit like um like get
you you um and it's a little bit like
it's kind of a weird
amalgamation of get in jquery you um
you grab a you use a selector and you
can grab
on an id or any attribute any parameter
um you can grab an element from that
state and you can modify it and then
when you're done modifying you commit it
and then
underneath it's going to diff it and
call a render function
and the concept of the render function
at least the html one
it's going to figure out just like react
the least amount of changes
to the browser that has to make to to to
make that change so it's so it's it's
not an immediate it's a it's not an
immediate mode type of rendering
if you hadn't if you had like an opengl
renderer it would just render the whole
thing a new every time but
and it you can't really do that in html
it's too slow
um and then so you this is just closure
but there's also a lot of convenience
functions so
here's me adding a class and closure
just with
associate and then there's some
you know plus class out of class they're
they're equal they're equivalent
yes what is the type of the thing like
are you if you have a custom map type
that you're using there or like what is
the result of the dollar sign function
um the result of the dollar sign is one
of these
so it's just a closure map yep it's it's
a nested map and it's the same format
that you get
when you use the default xml parser and
and parse it in html
yeah so everything everything has um a
tag
uh attributes and content those are like
three main
things in the map but i i use the map
for other things too
extra things um okay so that's that
oh great okay i get to try something um
so let's hopefully these will all work
so here's an example of that
so i have a function here i
this red box happens to be called has an
id
called state examples i think i can
actually show
what that looks is this oh you know i
didn't test this before
i think i you need a mean
okay this isn't ideal um i may have to
go back to this one
i will i promise um
okay so um
so yeah
so we can uh yeah right we can we can
load in
um html you can just write it enclosure
you can also load in svg
so it's so one one thing that i've been
doing a lot is if i have some data and
let's say i want to
graph it i can
draw like an adobe illustrator my graph
and parse it in into
this same state object and then i think
i can
attempt this now
so i'm just evaluating evaluating the
code
um in real time
sorry guys
i think it's worth it to go through this
process
um
i did have some technical difficulties
when i came in tonight
i had to reboot
um you get to see light table in action
um so what i'm doing now is i'm setting
up i'm using light table
to set up a web socket between my laptop
and the phone itself and i'm going to be
able to compile
compile uh code in real time
unfortunately i need to refresh this
um
i you know i have to do this because
this is the whole
this is like the whole point of the talk
skip ahead
it did and i just that's what i was
manipulating here
um so thank you that's important
um
any other advice
okay um i'm going to i'm going to cruise
along
did you hide the heart rate on purpose
yeah
it actually since since i restarted
since i restarted the app
um it's i have to explicitly connect
that again
but i'm this is kind of a bummer i'm
gonna cruise along um
so we is everyone pretty
satisfied with how you add stuff and
yeah
and okay now how do you make
bring it to life um is the next part so
we can add html we can add
svg um we can do it dynamically also
so how do we make stuff happen is the
next part
and this is where behaviors come in and
this this concept of behavior
comes from chris granger's work on light
table uh he does it this
very close to this um but all you really
have to do
is you define um a behavior so
earlier we had def tag here we have deaf
behavior
and we define the name of the behavior
here it's test
and then in our tag we just add a new
thing called behaviors and then we have
a vector
of the actual behaviors we want that
thing to have
so that and you can add these
dynamically as well
um yeah so this one just um
this one just pops up a pop-up um
so these are dynamic two um and i'm
still hoping
that maybe at the end i'll be able to
get this working but
you can define these as you go um you
can change them
um and and that's it so what are the
behaviors that
it currently supports i'm just trying to
make it add them
for um so the let me just so there's the
name of the behavior itself and then
there's the event so this map
could get really really long because you
can use any of these
um there's also there's ones they're
ones for keys as well
i'm focusing these are the the screen
touch ones so
things like uh holding down on the
screen tapping double
tapping dragging stuff around pinching
rotating all the stuff people do on the
phone
yeah a transform is like any um
it's it's it's either a scale or a
rotate
it's like either a pinch or a twist
um and then there's
behaviors based on other inputs
so the um that whole business with
touching the screen is fine
but we can actually have um
we can create our own things that the
system already knows about
um touch this touch that but it doesn't
know about heart rate
so we have a def input and this is
not really this this part is kind of new
but i have a def
input and you give it um a key which is
heart rate
and then and and you need to give it a
schema
so the way that i give it schema is you
just give it a piece of fake data that
has the same
shape of what you're actually going to
give it so i'm the way i'm dealing with
um in in the heart rate plug-in it's
just a
beats per minute um you know it's just a
single
item with with a key and then now that
i've done that
i can go ahead and use it in a behavior
so this one could have um you know it
could have
touch release all those things but here
it also has heart rate
i should say although i'm not going to
talk about server too much when you do
this
it also tells the server that this is a
new piece of data that you're going to
be getting someday
so make a schema for it and get the
database ready and
you know get ready to marshal it
um and so
that is pretty much um the conclusion
of the uh of the talk i'm i'm i would
like to
uh maybe we can ask questions and while
we're doing that i'll try to like get
the
actual demo set up on your
phone or something it's not that it's
the it's the con
it's the connection between my phone and
light table
is the issue so um
but yeah yes
um it's um it's it's very new so we just
started a couple weeks ago
and it's um it's closure it's daytonic
and closure yeah just for fun
so you know another thing this that type
of
um you know one one thing about
that is not really part of this talk but
this you know these data these schemas
are just closure
so all so that the server can read that
without any extra work
um so everything get that's getting
passed back between the phone
and the server is just closure data
structures um so i mean this is the
close
this is the closure meetup so why not
you know really do it up
so you touched on this
i mean is that the idiomatic way to wrap
other things
i think the way to um so i'm i'm not
yeah i'm not using titanium um
so i think the best way if you wanted to
use titanium i think that would be a
different renderer
i think everything would be the same but
that would be a different renderer you
would render
titanium components instead of just pure
html
or you know or if let's say you had um
you had an
app that's just an opengl canvas
then you would just have a different
renderer for that but i think you you
could just use the same data structure
sure it's uh it's based very highly on
facebook's react
um so react is all javascript um
it's all javascript virtual dom so you
you manipulate a javascript dom and then
it figures out the smallest path
to realizing that image in the browser
so if let's say you just you you change
your dom and what you do a lot of
calculations you change your dom
all that winds up changing is like one
string and one component
all it does is is uh is set
text content or whatever the the
javascript call is on that one component
you know so it keeps it maintains
everything
and just figures out by diffing what's
changed yeah
you're not using react are you doing
that i'm so i'm doing so
my solution is similar to react except
the the virtual dom
is enclosure it's not in javascript sure
yeah i'm asking if you do the yes
yeah not as well as they do
so yeah you've done that how do you map
that to
an instruction and unfortunately that's
a change
um once once i change once i once you've
done the div you know what's
what's different have you then i have a
slide for that
i have a slide for that actually that i
stole
it looks like this
so the the way that i do it and the way
that react also does it
it's they only do
they only really compare level like
level by level
um because that's usually how the order
that's usually how things change
if if the if a certain branch
of the tree so like let's say this was
that
map i had that was app this was the menu
bar
that was something else and then these
are those children so this is how that
whole thing gets parsed out we just kind
of com we just kind of compare
and if we look at them and first of all
we look at
the um if the tag changed um
then we actually create a new component
because you can't like switch a tag in
html
um and then if an attribute changes we
just do set attribute
if it's children if the count of the
children
changed we try to figure out if they
added something or remove something
and then and there's there's another
albums the fig algorithm to figure out
if there was sorting going on
so we just kind of try to replay you
know
replay the the change from the old
version the old dom and the new dom
in the fewest amount of steps um to
you know to render it
um do the uh do you apply the div during
the diff process or
as a secondary pass like do you create a
gif
do you refine a data structure i
i tried that i'm doing it the first way
now
um where i'm doing it as i'm diffing um
what i
would love to do is create a ref like
create a data structure from i actually
am not even using
data diff i'm kind of doing more
more i'm more i'm walking and um
and so i think there's a lot of better
ways to do the diff i think that's like
one thing that really could use some
some help
you have multiple renderers for each i
it's um it's it's one major it's one
major render and it's just
the um the javascript runtime on the
browser so
i'm doing you know the i mean it's it's
is it rendering yeah it's rendering it's
making colorful stuff but
what it's really doing is adding
components when it needs to removing
components when it needs to
and changing components when it needs to
um so i guess
it's uh there's retain
transformation yes
yeah yeah so i think that's called
there's there's um immediate mode
rendering which is like opengl where you
run you render the whole thing at once
and then there's retain mode rendering
which you keep stuff around and you only
render the changes this is this retain
mode
yeah so you said that you started this
before you heard
how you're doing all this stuff yeah you
know reproducing what facebook
react is doing and stuff on your own
home is already
doing that quite well are you aware that
david nolan was sitting in the
background
uh who's that guy who created it oh no
way
hi david um yeah i
i yeah i mean you should just i should
hang out with david
exactly and this is why i didn't spend a
lot of time on that okay
of course i acknowledge it but i got
pretty far before i found out about it
so it's just i think that part that that
diffing
in part could just be swapped out
i mean it seems like i'm thinking all
software anything that's unreliable and
doesn't work should be replaced with
something
that's reliable and that works i think i
did it okay
but if i would certainly evaluate um you
know the ohm stuff
and see if it it works better and
actually i think the um
i do like the principle of having
the virtual dom be closure what what do
you what do you think
so your your virtual dom is john is well
let's just just react and the only
reason we stuck with that
i'm not interested in that problem yeah
and they're they're working on that they
have lots of devs and they're
constantly optimizing it yeah so i'm
just i'm just not concerned with that
that problem yeah yeah i'm not too into
that problem either to be honest
yeah it's not that interesting it's
important but it's not that interesting
um
yes
it's so it's html5 um so it's the same
renderer
um and so it's using and i was talking
about
the um apache cordova stuff before
so what that is just a layer of
abstraction
between the html which is
platform independent and
the underlying hardware which is
platform dependent so it's just a bridge
so the the um the actual like the
bluetooth stuff
i have to rewrite that or um fortunately
someone else wrote it and so there's
like a lot of plugins for cordoba and
they're platform specific
so you may have a diff like in some
cases it's the same plug-in that
someone's ported
to like every device like the the older
more robust ones that's the case
in some cases you have to mix and match
in some cases you have to write your own
um
but yeah the idea is you need
you know you if you really want to do
something um
in you know on the hardware directly um
on ios you've got to do it in objective
c
and on android you've got to do it in
java or one of the other languages that
it has
um well this i give myself like a b-plus
here
but i think we could wrap up just one
last suggestion about trying to get your
work um remember you have to like copy
and paste
that what sort of thing that it creates
yeah that's that's what i think
yeah i've been kind of going into um
into this thing
yeah it's you know this is one of those
murphy's law things
i'm actually happy because when i came
in and plugged in the monitor
my screen went completely dark
so this is like this this is like yeah
this is okay
i think what probably the best thing for
me to do at this point
is to um do like
maybe an annotated demo in in a video
format um
also i'm i'm having difficulty
connecting to a network and
i think that's part of my problem too um
so i think probably the best way for me
to do that part of the demo
is maybe like in a video format and then
you know i can just post it and put the
link on the meetup site or
eventbrite or wherever else it was
a sort of status report can you daily
usage what works really well
so the
i would say what's working really well
is the
um just the creating nodes the modifying
them and adding behaviors to them
and um there's
again like the in the um
for example the touch library like i
didn't that's
an open source live you know that's
that's all another project so
yeah it's it's really i mean this is
really an integration project that's why
like to for me to pick up and start
using ohm or or react or whatever
is it's no big deal um because i've had
um many many different libraries and i
prefer when they come when they compile
with
g closure when they when they work in
advanced compile mode that's the one
little pickiness i have and react does
not david does it
i there was i kind of got it to work
consistently
yeah that's that's sort of what i
figured so you just you have like an
externs file
extern then we have you can just
concatenate it to the front of the file
yeah yeah so stuff like that so
i i mean it really this whole thing
really is about integration it's
not i and i wish i had a slide about
this like my goal is actually to make
something very uninnovative
that's it is that okay oh
so i need to use the so it's it's
getting this to connect to this so this
this local host is this
right so i have this and my internet
right now
is a usb bridge
it's kind of a yeah it's not
it's high level of difficulty sorry guys
but i will do that video i promise
um oh one other thing so this is not
um this hasn't been released yet i i
would like to release it soon
i'm i'm not ready um but if anyone
uh is interested in like seeing the code
or working on it with me i'd probably
i'd rather just do it old school for a
little while
just with a small group and not like a
public thing
so just you know introduce yourself
and i'll give you my card and we'll just
do it old school
so um i'll just do it very briefly
um light table is i think the best thing
the best place to start
is with and this is these are the like
principles
that i wanted to show anyway but you
have it's going to evaluate your code as
you type it
so for instance in um if i do
test
i don't know why i did an atom first but
it's just evaluating that
and then if i go on to a new line
it's going to evaluate you know it might
error for a little while but it's it's
kind of this real time
repel um and that i think that's that's
what it really is
yes it does yeah it's just totally
dynamic
um yeah it's uh it's i think it's maybe
a year too old um it's fairly new it was
open source in january
it has um you can write your own plugins
now
and it has i i can use it pretty well
because it's all about tags and
behaviors
um yeah
yeah you can just create functions
that's not very interesting one
but um i'm so used to closure script
it's just
print right to print okay
so the second that that evaluated it
printed out there
that's the idea so it just it's cons
your program is just constantly
reevaluating as you type and it's um
it's just interesting yeah i mean it's
very similar to the rebel except it's
just one
control return you don't have to hit and
and you don't have to
you you don't have to be
it's more than that absolutely yeah um
it's uh but you don't this insurrept
mode you don't have to be in that mode
you can use it more like a
rebel yeah
you just type stuff yeah and so i can do
if i want to
it's just really fast and i can navigate
the i could search for a file in my
project
um it's it's really quite nice it has um
you can kind of change it's so yeah
there's
nothing in there but you can kind of
change how it behaves as you go
um so the first thing i did when i came
in was this
or the opposite of that
so it just you know changed the behavior
in that case just the font which maybe
isn't too interesting
but you could just change how all the
editors were um
as you go and you're never really out of
this context
of you and closure you're always in that
you're always in that space
because this is disclosure
so we'll probably hang out here for a
few more minutes if you have any more
questions you know feel free to come up
um otherwise we usually every time go to
a bar around the corner called the group
street bar
to continue talking and that is um
it's at the intersection of broome and
west broadway the easiest way to get
there is to follow somebody else
so and people will sort of you'll see i
don't know where it is
i just got lucky
in that case then okay just real quick
real quick
i needed you to run interference
that's like why magicians have like the
assistant so they
can figure out the next trick well okay
so i'll go down to state examples
so yeah i can just cruise around
um so there's this i think state
examples
that did not work
oh it did a bunch at once um let me try
again
so this is showing you in real time
visually
this is yeah that's that and that's what
i was trying to
demonstrate the whole time but it's it's
how it actually happens so
um so uh
you know i showed that slide earlier of
the
the mac thing where you type the code in
and then you hit
play and then you wait it comes up um
so this is the counter to that this is
real time
so let's see
um so i just in one step i put um
i just executed this block and it put a
green border around it
it changed the background color to gray
and it added
a button um
so not too interesting i could just keep
adding
and then here let's see
change the colors of all the buttons
and then let me yeah and then so this
was the
svg thing that i loaded before um so
there's no
in this library there's no difference
between manipulating a vector drawing
and manipulating
a an html element so
i can it looks like i'm about to change
it to orange
and make it smaller um and then i can if
i want to know what i'm dealing with
i can always um
print this this is even maybe more
important than changing things
is being able to inspect what you're
doing in real time
so i just printed out what that tag
looks like
you know what it has in it um
and there's um what else is there oh
there's like um
there's unlimited undos so every time
and this is just natural since i'm
saving the state
i can just kind of play it back i could
actually so i'm just going back in time
literally
i could give the app a timestamp
and it will return its state to that
moment in time
and so that the the reason that's
important is for concurrency
let's say you have a multiplayer game or
a multiplayer application
you can share the state or that's how
it's designed to share the state around
um yeah
i mean what else um
is that suffice or is that that's not
enough
pretty good